nearly three weeks into this war and
Ukraine's president walks freely on the
streets of the capital cave
Vladimir zielinski visited staff at a
hospital today he is leading this nation
through a war but this was as much about
a photo call as it was a morale booster
get well I wish you health be strong
well done guys
strength is what they need right now
because this is the northeastern city of
kharkiv
a city pounded into submission
I have seen here on this street
and this is Maria and she explains how
Ukraine's second largest city is now
paralyzed over there you would see the
University Building
a very Lively area it's hard to imagine
how civilians can be attacked that is
after all a war crime
this is
and yet this block of flats in
chennehive was struck by a rocket
in urban just north of Kiev Fierce
fighting
an American photojournalist Brent
Renault was killed in an attack by
Russian forces another journalist was
injured it's not clear who they were
working for
but time here is running out for those
trying to escape the fighting
our building was hit with a missile and
two apartments next to ours were just
smashed we've got cases of looting so
it's just horrible very very horrible
there are signs that the Russians are
trying to destroy democracy too after
what's thought to be the kidnap of the
mayor of military Paul by Russian troops
here appearing to be led away forcefully
at the top of the screen a new leader
has been instated brought in by the
occupation she's pro-russian
our main task now is to adapt to the new
reality so that we can begin to live in
a new way as soon as possible
Ukraine's foreign minister accused
Russia of abducting a second Regional
mayor
in the Black Sea port of Odessa a key
Target for the Russian Advance they are
waiting for the war to reach them Nick
Martin Sky News hello how are you fancy
here I meet the mayor of Odessa Gennady
tookenov he admits he's afraid but also
angry
Russia are trying to justify their
actions by saying that NATO is expanding
its borders he tells me but no one
attacked Russia and no one was going to
this is nonsense
at the city's Central Market you could
be forgiven for thinking this is just
another day the Stalls are busy
it feels very much like people are
stocking up here getting in fresh fruit
and vegetables cured meats because the
truth is the Airaid Sirens have begun to
sound and we've also heard explosions in
the distance
and people can't be sure whether this
time next week this Market will even be
open
these refugees are from the bombed city
of mikalayov just a hundred kilometers
from Odessa they've now made it to the
safety of Romania
2.7 million people have now left Ukraine
and the numbers are rising each day Nick
Martin Sky News Odessa